[Music]
how's everyone doing great great yeah
welcome having fun so far
learning stuff yeah both at the same
time great yeah thank you very much my
name is Karen ticket of Mike Lee's Vince
and Julie all three of us a customer
engineers Google cloud and we're going
to present you this session a modern
data pipeline in action we're going to
walk through a few a data pipeline from
collecting data processing the data
analyzing the data and talk about
discuss about the best practices and
considerations all right so let's just
quickly recap what data pipeline is what
it is for as you can see different
stages usually exist in that modern data
or data pipeline usually it starts with
data ingestion we have to collect the
data take the data in it could be coming
from service users or IOT devices these
days once you have collected the data
with the transform it cleanse it some
kind of processing we then have to store
the data procedure somewhere sometimes
file system storage device or maybe in a
data warehouse and then once we have the
data in we can take a look and see what
we can derive from the data and the old
days it could be a simple s like an
aggregation summation group ID a group
by week or maybe these days it could be
very common to do some statistical
modeling or maybe use it for advanced
use cases like machine learning ai and
then visualization is a very very
important step usually that is used for
presenting the results of the analysis
you know pie chart bar chart new clink
diagrams word cloud you name it you have
different types of visualization
techniques
usually these stages done in a
orchestrated in an automated fashion I
mean it could start with for example a
presence of the data file some events
coming in some trigger or maybe the
trigger is based on a batch schedule
although there are cases that maybe it
is done manually during development
phase testing vase or maybe it is for ad
hoc analytics project we do hear a lot
of challenges from customers we're
trying to build data pipeline these days
and they incur encountering different
types of things starting with ingestion
that could be huge volume of data coming
in they're coming in in different format
at very high speed and then the
transformation it could be tough to just
cater for all of those requirements that
are required by the downstream
application you have to add in all those
transformation rules you have to keep
adding adding adding unto a point that
I'm not sure whether you all have the
experience of like talking to your data
integration team hey I just want to
understand how come the incoming data
file has like a million rows and then
you're dropping 10% of time they got
rejected they God put somewhere else
what happened and then it's just getting
harder and harder to understand what
happened in between the pipelines and
it'll storage itself I mean with the
huge volume of the storage it is really
getting tough as a exercise on its own
just to architect the storage system
just to make it highly available make it
durable make sure that things are back
up correctly make sure it can handle
this throughput that is coming in and
then the size of the storage will grow
and you have to figure out how to add
the storage in a way that is not
impacting the system and then it can
still catch up with the requirements of
the IAP the throughput and things like
that and then when we get to the
analysis of the data well there are many
cases that so many different users
having their own queries to run you have
to figure out a way to tune it for this
user and then tuna for another group of
users and
with of course with the data volume keep
adding to where the curious may run slow
and slower so it's not like a one-off
exercise you have to keep monitoring it
you know all those things like analyze
it like a run stats on it all those
things just to keep it up and running
and make it efficient well there's some
other cases that the data it's not even
in one single place I mean they're in
different types of storage in different
data Mart's they're just in different
places to get your heart to analyze and
finally unofficial ization
there's so many cases that I've seen in
a customer situation they have a bi
dashboard but then the caveat is that
the data available for visualization
sorry it is just the latest three months
of the data if you're having good luck
in your company maybe okay it's a one
year of data three years of data in your
dashboard and may not be all the data
set you want to analyze people are doing
this usually to optimize for performance
of Curie's so it's not overly loading
the dashboard and to be honest in the in
many of the cases you don't get to run
the dashboard yourself it will be run
centrally by someone else you know an
administrator a server generating the
report for you 8:00 a.m. in the morning
weekly report they send you a PDF the
PDF has a chart you attach the PDF and
that becomes your reporting repository
so I know this session title is called a
modern data pipeline in action we say
action I mean it's just trying to find
some action that is fun on a Thursday
afternoon so let's play a game
so shall we so I'm going to introduce my
colleague Vince on the stage and he'll
guide you through a game as the action
piece in this session all right Vince
thank you
hi everyone so what we did was we built
a demo we thought that rather than
pounding through a whole bunch of slides
instead we'd get you involved in
actually building our data pipeline in
action so on the screen here you'll see
a bitly link if you'd like to take out
your phones and hit this bitly link in a
browser you'll be taken to an
application that we built for you to
actually generate the data that we'll
put into a data pipeline and we'll
visualize the results here in the room
in real time your participation here is
not required but if you'd like to see a
data pipeline in action it'd be really
great if you played along with us so
please if you haven't already take your
phone out hit this bitly link in your
browser and you'll be presented with a
simple quiz game in the quiz game it's
really easy they're multiple choice
questions you hit the button for the
correct answer and then answer the next
question I'll give you guys a few
seconds to answer as many questions as
you can before we resume
so while you're playing we'll switch to
the demo laptop please and what you'll
see here is a dashboard as your as your
answers flow in will see this dashboard
update in real time
nice to see those numbers moving up as
you all play the game
cool so what you see here is a real-time
dashboard that we built with the help of
our friends at looker we've got a couple
of sort of individual metrics that we
display on the screen to show the number
of active users people who have all the
people of all time who have taken our
quiz and then we've got a little time
series chart that shows how many answers
are being put in per per minute
these things are updating on slightly
different refresh schedules so that's
why you may see the answers per minute
delaying a bit but these answers are
actually moving through our data
pipeline as we as we stand here can we
switch back to the presentation please
now what are we solving with this data
pipeline usually what we hear from our
customers is that there's a handful of
things that they're solving for when it
comes to building out a data pipeline
one of the things that's often the case
is that we want to get timely access to
the data usually people don't want to
have to wait for days or even hours to
get access to data to start analyzing it
and looking for insights and so we don't
want to have to wait for long drawn-out
ETL processes to complete before we can
actually start querying the data we may
also have people in our organization who
we want to when able to make data-driven
decisions but don't have very high
degree of technical skill they don't
program in Python or are or even sequel
and so we need to enable everyone in no
organization to make decisions with data
with tools that are easy for them to use
and finally your data engineers are out
there building the tools for these other
constituencies to use your data
engineers actually also need a way to
process data consistently and then when
business rules change or when bugs are
found they may need to actually go back
and reprocess the data that had been
already processed by the by the
streaming engine let's look at how we
solve for this
this is the architecture of the game you
just played you can see that we are
going from the user that's you through
our application we ingest data from the
app deliver the events down to some
processing layer which prepares the data
for analysis we store the data in an
analytics engine where we can query over
the data build reports and dashboards
and then finally we've got mechanisms
within these tools to actually share the
data out so let's dive a little bit
deeper on the application what we did
was use firebase to implement the
front-end that you were playing with we
use firebase hosting for all of the
static assets the HTML the JavaScript
and so forth we used fire store to store
the questions and your answers to those
questions and then we use cloud
functions to react to the submission of
the answers in the app and we also use
the cloud function to react to the
updates of the fire store database in
real time those functions are then
emitting data into a cloud pub/sub topic
cloud pub/sub is a server 'less way to
deliver events from an application an
IOT sensor what have you store it
durably and then deliver it later for
processing the other side of the coin
from a pub sub topic is a pub sub
subscription a subscription is used to
actually deliver events down to
interested consumers you can have up to
10,000 topics and and subscriptions in a
GCP project we're only using a handful
of topics and subscriptions in order to
to accommodate your answers as they flow
in our consumer is a cloud dataflow
pipeline dataflow is a fully managed
service for ingesting sorry not for
ingesting but for processing events
preparing them for later analysis if the
data preparation may involve just basic
transformations taking the data that's
ingested in our case we're ingesting
JSON data performing some computation
over it we might be computing say a
score over the over the data and then
storing that into some sink in our case
we're using bigquery now if I were
delivering this talk a year ago I'd
probably have a screenshot of a snippet
of some Java code that was reading from
pub/sub optionally doing some
transformation in the middle and then
storing the data into bigquery
not everybody's Java developer but it's
often the case that we need to be able
to deploy these kinds of pipelines
simply so we've recently added to the
cloud platform a number of pre-built
dataflow templates that allow you to
easily ingest data from a source and
write it to a sink optionally
transforming it as it passes through a
Java Script UDF that you can provide
with these provided templates you can
get data from cloud pub/sub into things
like bigquery or cloud storage without
writing a single line of code in our
case what we're doing is ingesting from
pub/sub processing that data minimally
and then writing it into bigquery we're
also writing an archive out to cloud
storage as a bunch of Avro files we
chose the Avro format because it's
extremely well supported by all of the
other GCP components it's a first-class
citizen with respect to bigquery ingest
and all of the rest of the suite of big
data tools on the platform you already
saw the dashboard that we showed you a
bit ago from looker looker is a great
tool it has excellent support for
bigquery and is really very nice to work
with as I can attest but it's not the
only option you have for for visualizing
your data
Google data studio is built directly
into the cloud platform and is free to
use it's a great way to really
democratize the ability of people in
your organization to create
visualizations and share that out to the
rest of the organization and there's a
long list of other BI and visualization
tools that are supported by our partners
I talked about the data engineers need
to be able to reprocess data and maybe
go back and recalculate things the cloud
storage archive is what enables this so
having stored our events in an archive
on cloud storage as a bunch of Avro
files should a data engineer need to do
so we can write another pipeline that
might go back and reprocess all of that
data out of cloud storage before writing
it again to our eventual sync this is
usually run as something like a batch
job in contrast to the streaming
pipeline that you saw earlier what's
great about this framework and date
cloud dataflow in particular is that if
I fix my bug or change my business rules
in my streaming pipeline those
transforms that I use for the streaming
pipeline can usually be used pretty much
directly in a batch pipeline that runs
alongside this is how we enable the
reprocessing of data the recalculation
Restatement of results when you run a
batch pipeline it's not always the case
that the batch pipe that the batch
pipeline that you're looking to execute
is the only thing that needs to run you
usually need some way to orchestrate
this there might be dependencies that
have to be satisfied before executing
the batch pipeline creating a database
creating a table executing a different
data flow job or executing some bash
script we recently announced the general
availability of cloud composer which is
based on Apache airflow Apache airflow
is a service for orchestrating complex
data pipelines particularly of the
style that that I'm describing here a
cloud composer is a managed service for
airflow and makes it really easy to set
up and manage and run an airflow cluster
now that I've taken you through the
architecture
I'd love to welcome Cayenne back to the
stage to give you a little bit of a
deeper dive into some of our
architecture choices Thank You Vince
alright think of install guiding us
through the modern data pipeline in
action so I would like to go back and
revisit it and then take a look at some
of the architecture decisions that we
have made when presenting this solution
of course just now the example is a game
in your use case may or may not be a
game it could be like in a traditional
enterprise environment could be some
other kinds of data processing needs we
still want to revisit it or maybe go
through some of those architecture
decisions to see if there's something
Universal maybe there's something that
you can borrow and then apply in your
data pipeline in your environment
first of all just now the data flows
from five days the application that you
used your phone to play on and then it
eventually goes into bigquery for the
dashboard for the analytics technically
speaking it is actually doable
technically feasible to have the data
written from firebase into bigquery
directly as a matter of fact bigquery
actually supports multiple ways of
ingesting data bakery can ingest data in
batch bakery on the other hand also has
a streaming in certain mechanism that
means when you run a sip o statement
it actually can merge the data merger
results between a streaming buffer in
bigquery with the data that it has been
persisted in the table already so it is
actually very very doable to have Phi
base write the data to bakery directly
we choose not to do that which used to
put something in between
and that is what we call decoupling in
this case we want the application in
this case in this example firebase to
focus only on publishing the source data
the source data from the application in
its original format in this case it is
JSON data and just focuses on publishing
the data on to the cloud pub/sub topic
the application doesn't need to be aware
of hey what is the dataset name down the
road hey where is big hurry or some
other databases
what is the dataset name what is a table
name how the schema looks like and then
in many cases it may not be one single
downstream application right now it
could be one it could be a second one
later and it can grow and we don't want
to have so many of those touch points
built into the sauce application in this
case having tops up in this case we'll
make sure that firebase the source
application only focuses on publishing
the data and then it will let pops up be
the mechanism to fan out the data to
have multiple subscribers subscribing to
the same topic each cloud pops up topic
supports up to 10,000 subscribers you
don't need your handle to design your
own fan on Magnusson pops up can do it
for you the concept of message bus
service bus like this is not new to be
honest it has been around people that
talk about a message layer message queue
stream storage this is not new to be
honest but at the same time it has been
a little bit come challenging to
architect this kind of solution that
what my issues that you may have heard
around my messages stuck in a queue the
processing cannot keep up with the
incoming data volume or if you're lucky
to have a solution that is horizontally
scalable it has multiple partitions
multiple shots then you need to worry
about how should I shut it how should i
punish in it the source application may
need to calculate the sharding make sure
that it is evenly distributed
if it is not even a distributor how do
you split a shot to rebalance it
rebalance it it becomes the architecture
exercise on its own to deliver this kind
of message solution in this case in our
example cloud pub/sub it's a fully
managed service running on Google cloud
platform it is a global service that's
one single endpoint around the globe
meaning that when you are publishing
your messages to the topic you don't
need to worry about
hmm mi Paulo by publishing my messages
to us the Europe to Asia no you are
publishing your messages to pops up and
pops up or handle the rest you don't
need to worry about which publishing or
which shot you're publishing your
messages to cloud pops up which is scale
automatically for you and you're just
paying for the data volume that you're
sending to cloud pops up the processing
layer Cloud dataflow it restated from
pops up there could be varying volume of
data coming in throughout the days or
the week holiday season there are many
of those similar processing framework
that can do something like this
horizontally scalable manner but at the
same time that horizontal factor usually
is a fixed factor meaning that you
design an upfront hey whether it is for
noobs 10 noobs 10,000 knows you have to
have a fixed set of computing power in
order to consume the messages on the
other hand cloud dataflow can actually
do something like auto scaling based on
the incoming data volume coming from
streaming or maybe even from batch
cloud dataflow has the ability to scale
up and scale down the computing
resources underneath so that you can
adjust it and only pay for the resources
that you are truly consuming there's no
need to over provision your streaming
processing layer just to cater for the
high-water mark and then in this case
the destination of the data bakery
it has compute storage separation
meaning that when the data volume grows
you don't need to
necessary tighter storage cost with the
computing cost like the CPU and a memory
you pay for the storage and the
processing separately this makes it
simple elastic and low-cost when we are
sending data to the destination under
the consideration under the architecture
decision is how do you want that data to
look like traditionally speaking I've
been in that kind of feel like an ETL
jobs trying to fit into the data schema
on the data warehouse all those things
as simple as like an normalization of
the data the star schema slowly changing
dimension just all those ETL jobs
they're not really doing something that
is business-wise but more to cater for
the target database format usually the
goal is to fit in a schema so that it is
efficient for the database Curie's or
maybe it will minimize the data storage
so that you're minimizing the
duplication saving the storage cost on
the other hand in a modern data pipeline
we can ease off on some of these
transformations in-between the reason is
that in a modern data pipeline
especially it for example in this case
what we have in big hurry
which you don't have to force it to be
like a one to many relationship table to
split up the data into multiple places
in a modern data pipeline a storage
system like bigquery when we're talk
about storing the structured data you
have the ability to store it in a format
that is as close to the source as
possible in this case there could be
arrays that with drugs they're pre
complex data types in the originating
source system and you can persist the
data as is as close to the source format
as possible so that you don't need to
worry about hundred break down the data
into this table that table how does the
ER diagram look like in things like that
this allows the data processing to be
really fast we minimize the logic
minimize anything that may happen in
between and we can have low latency
access to the data that is our goal
in the example we had just now we showed
a streaming example all of us offers in
a room are playing with row and then
sending the data so that is dreaming
data in real life situation streaming
may not be the only data source usually
you will be handling a mixture of
streaming data sources and batch data
sources they could be the same data type
they might be different so it is very
important architect decision to choose
something that you are not necessarily
like writing to separate data pipelines
or to separate pieces of curves cloud
dataflow supports both streaming and
badge meaning that when you're using the
underlying programming model you write a
set of transformation logic you write
something some algorithm it is very very
easy to have that same piece of logic to
work on streaming data and also batch
data so keep this in mind when you're
designing your data pipeline to make
sure that it is flexible enough to
handle both cases one use case as Vince
mentioned earlier is on the reprocessing
needs it could be based on changing
business requirements or you have to go
back and fix something but very very
often data is a very very valuable asset
there are so many cases that there might
be some insights hidden in the raw data
that may be in the future maybe there's
an upcoming analytics project someone in
your organization just want to go back
to the data and take a look and see if
there's some additional insights that
you can get out of the raw data that
could have come in like a months or
years ago so it is also very important
to when you're designing your data
pipeline to keep reprocessing as one of
the considerations you want to make it
easy for anyone in your organization to
just go back and say hey I have an idea
I want to take a look at the old data
and see if there's a certain kind of
pattern and then I can come up with this
new protection algorithm which has to be
trained based on O'Day
that's why reprocessing having this as
an architecture decision is important so
as supported by in my previous
livestream and badge reprocessing can
take advantage of stream and batch
capabilities in a cloud data flows
programming model and then you can go
back and process the existing data and
see what kind of additional insights
that you can get so here's kind of like
a flow chart on the high-level
transformations that might exist in
cloud dataflow pipeline in this example
first of all first step there four boxes
over there first box reads from the
cloud pops up topping a subscription
second passes the JSON message the third
step is to turn it into the bigquery
data flow at the table row format and
then the fourth step is to write to a
bakery you want to choose the
programming model that allows you to
express your pipeline and this kind of
like a high-level transformations so
you're not going to deal with all those
teeny little details the data program at
the data flows programming model
supports many other primitives that are
specialized for streaming data
processing like a windowing mechanism
for example sliding window fixed window
session window so it is very important
when you're designing your data pipeline
next time keep this in mind choose
something that allows you to express
your pipeline in these high level
primitives and when you're designing
something to be expressed in a
high-level manner it allows your data
pipelines to be portable just now I've
been talking about cloud dataflow cloud
dataflow in fact it supports pipelines
that are written in Apache beam SDK but
cloud dataflow is not the only option
the cloud dataflow does make it easy to
run your Apache beam data pipelines it
efficients the computing resources for
you it skills up scaled down it
rebalances to work like what we have
mentioned earlier but if you want to
choose to run it somewhere else you can
do that once you have written your data
pipeline in Apache beam Cloud dataflow
it's just one of the several supported
runners behind the scene you can say I
want to run my data pipeline on Apache
spark could be on I've actually apex
fling gear poem samsa or even locally
when you're doing development on your
workstation so when you are designing
your data pipeline you want to choose
something open so that on one hand you
can run it on for example cloud dataflow
on a cloud on the other hand if there
are some other requirements you can
choose to run it on your on-premise
environment or some of the environments
there shouldn't be any lock in so with
this said I'll pass the time to my
colleague Julie and then she'll explain
to you the customer stories the
customers who are running these modern
data pipelines on Google car platform
Thank You Julie
hello everybody thanks Cuyuna and thanks
Vince for walking us through the
concepts of a modern data pipeline and
the architectural decisions that go into
creating a modern data pipeline as
Caillou mentioned I wanted to take a
moment so to really make it real to talk
about how some companies are creating
modern data pipelines of their own and
GCP so all of the companies that you see
listed here are doing some really cool
things with big data analytics big data
processing all with Google cloud
services and some of them most of them
you've already heard about so the first
customer I wanted to talk about is Okada
Okada is an online grocery retailer they
serve over 70% of households within the
UK they don't have a single
brick-and-mortar store anywhere in the
UK so they're competing with all of
these really large stores that people go
past on their way home and so they
really need to find a way to get their
customers to be loyal to make sure that
they're always purchasing through them
so what they wanted to do was create a
big data analytics platform which would
help them convince customers of all of
the benefits of buying online as opposed
to in the stores and they also wanted to
make sure that they were using data to
drive their business insights to do
things like inform the supply chain
predict demand and really just overall
improve their logistics they had a
problem because their data was siloed
they had business data and products data
transactional data was all sitting in
different places across their data
center and they had no means of
communicating with each other so what
they knew they needed to do was come up
with a way to create a platform that
could pull all this data together and
they did that in GCP so they were able
to build this advanced analytics
solution that could not only process the
data through but run advanced analytics
against it to do things like determine
what would be best to improve customer
satisfaction how they could optimize
their supply chain how they could really
get access to insights about their
business data and closer to real-time
and ultimately reduce costs so all of
those kind of common business goals
almost every company has so they did
that by implementing first and foremost
bigquery as their data storage platform
so bigquery is where all of the data
ends up to be analyzed so they do
clickstream analysis customer analysis
product and and department analysis
everything you can think of all
happening in bigquery and this is across
over 2 petabytes of data they also are
using cloud dataflow for doing their
transformations so you might remember
Vince was talking about data flow quite
a bit as well and then they're using
pub/sub for all of their data delivery
so this kind of common pattern of
pub/sub data flow to bigquery and now
they took it even a step further by
integrating bigquery directly with
tensorflow and cloud machine learning
engine so kado was one of the very first
customers even helped us test the cloud
machine learning engine and what they
did was create these really awesome data
pipelines that do very real things so
one example of that is the way that when
somebody submits an order the items get
picked and packed and ready for delivery
so let's say I'm gonna make a curry for
dinner tonight and I put into my auto
app that I want some vegetables a
protein some lentils rice and some nice
naan bread it's around noon time right
I'm on my lunch not taking out my work
time with ordering my groceries and I go
ahead and enter that and that's when the
system starts to work really well
because now we have to analyze where are
these items in what warehouse what
warehouse is closest to where it needs
to be delivered are their perishables
what can be picked now what has to be
picked later and so it determines the
appropriate time to do these things and
send signals to the warehouses the
warehouses have a number of robots that
are used to automated you know to pick
all of the items in an automated fashion
but they just don't say hey you robot
you are responsible for Julie's order in
fact there's ml swarm intelligence that
they've created which will help the
robots work collaboratively so that they
can go through the warehouse and many
robots could be working on picking my my
items as well as others but making sure
that they all end up in the right
package to be shipped and making sure
that's all done
in such a way that everything ends up on
people's doors
freshers could be with no perishables so
it's really pretty cool what they've
done even still they're sending all of
the telemetry data from the robots up to
the cloud and they're analyzing that so
that they can do scheduling to make sure
they have the right number of robots on
the floor in each warehouse and to do
things like predictive wear and tear so
make sure that if some if they think
that something might happen to your
robot they can pull it and replace it
with a well working robot before
something happens it interrupts the
workflow so that's what they've done
internally using this modern data
pipeline and they also determines that
they do a really good job with
e-commerce and so they thought why don't
we create like an e-commerce platform
that we can sell to other customers to
large brick and mortars that also do
online and they created ok dos Mott
smart platform which leverages a lot of
these same types of pipelines to ensure
now that these other retailers across
the globe can deliver the same type of
like fantastic ecommerce experience that
oak auto does to their customers
now the next customer that I wanted to
talk about is bright Co so very
different company they're actually an
online video platform they serve content
for internet TV and news media a various
different internet media so thank all
video streaming and Brightcove runs 8500
years worth of video streaming of video
viewing each and every month they have 7
billion analytic events per day so
that's a lot of data 85,000 years worth
of video streaming per month for all the
people that are watching and so they
were having a problem because their
legacy system was kind of bursting at
the seams they knew that they needed sri
architect INRI platform and so they
investigated a number of different big
data stacks and they landed upon GCP and
so what did they do they implemented a
data flow that went from pub sub free
event delivery data flow for all of
their transformations and bigquery to
Land's their data and be able to perform
analytics and they chose this because
all of those services can scale to
whatever scale that they
you'd without them having to worry about
whether or not the infrastructure can
handle it so the story's a little bit
shorter than the last one but really
interesting nonetheless just because of
the grand scale with the amount of
information that moves through the
pipeline every single day and the amount
of information that get ana gets
analyzed every single day
and speaking of scale that brings us to
our last customer that I'd like to talk
about so is there any Spotify users in
here a few so I personally use Spotify
every day I absolutely love the service
so I was very excited to learn that
Spotify chose to put all of their tech
stack on GCP so we're not going to talk
about all of the tech stack we're just
going to talk about the cool stuff of
course the data stuff today
Spotify had the largest Hadoop
environments in Europe a 2,500 node
50,000 CPU core Hadoop environment with
100 petabytes of capacity 100 terabytes
of RAM so I just it makes me shudder at
the thought of like the expense of that
system but it was really important
because over 20,000 jobs were running on
the system per day from 2000 different
workflows it was supporting a hundred
different teams within Spotify so you
have to imagine there's very complex it
was very important they couldn't just
break it down and build it somewhere
else so they knew that they wanted to
get out of the on-prem world and out of
the single Hadoop cluster world and so
they chose to come to GCP and so if
maybe you might recognize the pattern
here what do you think they chose for
their ad-hoc analytics and data storage
they chose bigquery their bigquery
environment serves over 10 million
queries and scheduled jobs every single
day processes I'm sorry every single
month processes 500 petabytes of data
every single month for all of the
different users that need to query
against it also you might guess that
free event delivery
they chose pub/sub and if you remember
the scale of what Brightcove was doing
seven billion analytic events per day
Spotify has one trillion requests that
go against pub/sub and pub/sub is able
to scale to handle that normally just to
handle it but nine
9% of all requests that come through
pub/sub have a maximum latency of 400
milliseconds so I think they've gotten
to scale in the low latency pretty much
worked out for that part of the pipeline
now data processing again you might have
guessed they're using data flow they run
5,000 data flow jobs per day but they
also realized that they had some things
that that they wanted to continue to do
on Hadoop so there was some workloads
some ETL that they were doing in Hadoop
that they wanted to keep there and so
they also introduced another service
which we haven't really talked about
today which is called data proc and
that's our managed Hadoop environment
within GCP the big difference between a
traditional Hadoop environment and data
proc is that we're able to take and
decouple the storage from the compute so
now you can store your data in Google
Cloud storage and just a repoint your
Hadoop jobs to look at GCS instead of
HDFS and in doing that that enabled them
to have very workflow specific Hadoop
environments that only spin up when it's
time to run the job they spin back down
when it's finished and they only pay for
the compute resources when they
absolutely need them so you might have
seen I'm not sure if anybody sat in the
session yesterday but Spotify did a
session on their full migration from you
know app tier all the way down to to the
backend so if interested I definitely
recommend taking a look at that if you
want to see you know all of the thoughts
and considerations they went through
when designing their solution and GCP
but the moral of the story the reason
why I really bring it up today is
because it was huge for Spotify to no
longer have to worry about the scale of
infrastructure or the stretching of
infrastructure whether or not they had
what they needed for the amount of data
that was coming in or the growth that
was going to happen as they come with
you know new music licensing and your
users coming to this system now they can
just analyze the data understands
listener behaviors understand how music
tastes correlate and really build a
fantastic music streaming and music
recommendation experience for the
consumers so we're nearly there I know
this is the very last session of all of
next unless you're coming to boot camps
tomorrow
but before we separate there's a couple
of things we wanted to do first of all
does anybody want to know who might have
one quote-unquote one the quiz answer
the most questions right so you might
see on the side here in the upper right
hand corner of the app which you may
have logged out of already if you log
back in you're gonna see what your
username is we didn't want to put
anybody he's like email address or name
up on the screen so if we switch back
over to the dashboard we can have a look
and see who answered the most questions
correct and also who answers answered
the most accurately so let's see I can't
see that far if we can see who the user
is f o8 y x2 so it's not a requirement
but if you're still sitting in here and
you know that that's user you're a user
and you want a round of applause from
300 of your new best friends go ahead
and stand up it's a mystery and we also
have somebody who got 100% correct 80%
correct x j vs y2 so if you're here and
you want the recognition please go ahead
and stand up again not a requirement but
thank you all for playing the game and
for watching the modern data pipeline in
action if we could switch back to the
sides just a few more things before we
go first of all you have the opportunity
to make this real for yourselves so
everything that we showed you here today
everything that we built in this modern
data pipeline up and see the point of
the visualization you can build on your
own with this code lab so you you have
this link here you'll have access to the
slides as well additionally did I go too
fast
oh wait so I see all phones down all
righty initially there are additionally
there are also a number of sessions that
are relevant to what we talked about
here today
so there are sessions on firebase and
data flow on bigquery ends looker and
how well they operate together and if
you go ahead into the next website or
app and just filter by data and
analytics you'll be able to see lots of
things about the things we talked about
today finally we have some resources for
you to learn more to get started with
GCP if you don't already have an account
you can get a free trial account so that
you can build out this and that free
trial account will have more than enough
credits in it for you to run that
through and also if you could please
pleaseplease before you leave this room
open up the next app and fill out the
survey to let us know how we did so that
we can make sure that we make next
year's next even better than this we'd
really really appreciate it thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]